- I'm happy to introduce Ruti Regan,
and Ruti is a rabbinical
student from the
Jewish Theological Seminary of America,
board member and founder of Anachnu,
inclusion speaker and
trainer from New York.
And Ruti is going to talk to us about
when listening is complicated,
skills for honoring
the individual perspectives
of every person
with disabilities.
Ruti.
- Hello, everyone.
Everyone hear me?
Can the person next to you hear me?
(audience laughs)
Well, check, 'cause if you can't hear me
you probably didn't hear
the question, right?
So I'm Ruti Regan, I'm a rabbinic leader
in a couple of organizations
concerned with disability.
One of which is Matan,
which is an organization
that about 10 years ago was founded
to solve the problem of
Jewish kids with disabilities
not getting access to Jewish education.
What we used to doing
is mostly self-contained
Special Ed Hebrew school classes,
but we've realized that
kids really need education
within their own communities.
So now what we do is
train education directors,
educators, SEIT schools, how to increase
the inclusivity of their programs.
And I also work for Anachnu,
which is another Jewish
disability organization.
Anachnu means 'we' in Hebrew,
and the reason that's behind that is that
a lot of what I do, a lot of what we do,
is focused on getting out of the silos,
because I think that
we all need each other.
You know we have a lot of
great developments in medicine,
in social work, in special education,
in disability organizations, from parents.
And there's a lot of
barriers to collaboration
and to us knowing what we
all, and sharing knowledge.
And I think we all really need each other,
because dealing with disability
has a lot of unsolved problems
that are very difficult
on a number of levels.
And so what we've found is that
one of the most difficult
silos to get out of,
is the one regarding
disability perspective.
Because we're socialized to believe
that disability
perspective does not exist.
And even if we know better explicitly,
which I think most of us do,
to feel that people with
disabilities have needs,
people without disabilities
have perspectives.
I can't tell you how many times I've heard
'we're doing all these things
to meet this child's medical needs,
but how does his sister
feel about all of this?'
Well that's great, that's a
question we should be asking,
but also, how does he feel,
and what does he think?
And so, from a spiritual
leadership perspective,
and also from a service
provision perspective,
because a lot of it's pretty universal,
and also from a disability perspective,
I wanna talk about how
in various settings,
clinical and educational,
we can really acknowledge
in practical ways
that everybody has a perspective,
and that everybody's
perspective is important.
So let me just flip to
this slide here. Okay.
So, the thing that's core about this
is people really always have perspectives
whether or not we know what they are.
And sometimes there is no effective means
for knowing with either
certainty or any real accuracy
what someone's perspective might be.
And whether we know or not,
and again a lot of times we don't,
the perspective exists and it matters.
And we need to treat it as
both an unsolved problem
in figuring out more effective
ways for figuring out
what people are thinking when
there's communication barriers
but also a problem of what do we do now
when we haven't solved the problem,
or are in the process
of solving the problem
and there's this person before us,
who we may not know what they think,
but we want to recognize their humanity
in a way that is about
recognizing it to them,
and not just to society, not
just to their caregivers,
not just to people that might hurt them
if they think they're not human,
but to that person and everyone else.
So, we can't read people minds,
their minds are still there
and they're still important.
And one place this breaks down,
is when somebody has a
proxy decision maker,
because they either are in reality,
or have been determined by
someone else to not be someone
who's capable of
communicating their choices.
Somebody can be a proxy decision-maker,
they cannot be a proxy mind,
a proxy perspective-haver
or a proxy human.
Nobody is a proxy for
someone else's humanity.
And somebody's views exist,
matter, are important,
even if they have a proxy decision-maker,
even if we don't know
what their views are,
even if their views are being overridden.
And consent means something legally,
and it means something morally,
and even if there is legal
consent from someone else,
it matters when somebody's
consent in the sense of
their bodily integrity,
autonomy, views, choices
being overridden,
and part of recognizing
somebody's humanity is
acknowledging that,
taking that into account
in our decision-making,
and using language that reflects
the fact that it happened.
Because it's very
difficult to solve problems
that we don't acknowledge.
And it can be very painful
emotionally, spiritually,
to think of ourselves
as people who are doing
something against someone's
will that's distressing to them.
But even if it's the right decision,
even if we have to do
it, it's really important
to acknowledge what's happening,
and to remember that as bad
as we might feel about it,
it feels a lot worse to be
the person it's happening to,
and they shouldn't have
to feel that alone.
So respecting someone's
perspective is partly an attitude,
but a lot of it is embodied in practice.
And it's something that
I think that we all need
to work on continuously.
But one thing that I
think is really key about
recognizing humanity in practice,
is acknowledging that we're
making a lot of guesses.
We're making a lot of assumptions,
and we're going to be wrong
a high percentage of time,
when we're communicating with people
for whom there are
barriers to communication
in the sense of them understanding us,
and communication in the
sense of them telling us
what they think about it.
We're making guesses, we're
going to be wrong a lot,
and we're not going to be as competent
as we like to feel we are,
and as we are in areas
where there's more of
an established knowledge base.
And part of getting good at it,
is realizing that it's
an unsolved problem,
it's hard because it's hard.
It's not a failure, it's just that we have
received education on
all kinds of other things
that allow us to be really competent,
when we don't have received education,
we don't know certain
things, and it's okay,
and it's not a professional failure,
it's not a reflection on anyone,
it is an unsolved problem
that it's on all of us
to work on.
That said, there are certain assumptions.
Part of it is a matter of
working on making good assumptions,
part of it is learning
error correction mechanisms.
And there are certain assumptions
that we should be making.
One is, it's said a lot
in disability communities,
regarding communication:
silence is not absence.
When somebody isn't responding,
all you know is that
they're not responding.
You don't know what they're thinking,
you don't know what their
cognitive abilities are,
and we make a lot of
mistakes in that area,
so it's really good to err on the side of
assuming that people
who have brain activity
are capable of understanding
and have opinions
about what you're saying.
Whether they in fact do understand or not,
they are people who have
thoughts, feelings and
we should at least try
to explain things to
and at least try to listen to.
'Cause if we don't try we won't succeed.
And again, a lot of this is guessing.
And part of guessing well is being clear
about what you know, what you don't know,
and if you think you know something,
how do you know and how do you check?
So one thing that I
didn't put in the slides
that I think is important is
that part of good guessing
is cultural competence.
Because people with disabilities are not
interchangeable disabled people.
People with disabilities, disabled people,
come from somewhere, have a culture,
have a cultural background,
operate within a cultural context.
And not only that, but
they're not interchangeable.
We're not interchangeable within cultures.
For instance in the Bay Area,
I'm sure all of you are aware,
that a lot of parents
who are really crunchy
will swear up and down
that their kid hates sugar.
So cultural competence
involves recognizing that
they may well be wrong about that,
and that the kid has a
cultural reaction to sugar
and to being part of that culture,
which may be a number of things.
Less obvious examples is:
not all Jews keep kosher,
not all Jews will like
it if a person shows up
and makes certain assumptions
about how they feel
about gender, or what their
culture is, stuff like that.
But you should still probably
know when Passover is,
and there's a range of things
that people might be thinking,
feelings people might be
having around the holidays,
because working on making good assumptions
is part of improving your
ability to make good guesses.
So, another part of guesses,
making good guesses,
is that when you don't know,
it's important to try multiple things.
And the less responsive someone is,
the less evidence you have,
the more important it is
to try multiple approaches.
For instance, one thing
that I think is very much
consistently on the table
when we're talking about
developmental disability,
is the issue of simple language.
And for some people
simple language is great.
For some people using simplified language
can make all the difference
in their ability to understand things.
And for some people
using simplified language
completely breaks their ability to have
any idea what you're talking about.
Because there's a reason why
we use technical language.
Technical language increases
some kinds of clarity
and it sends certain
kinds of messages in a way
that's more understandable.
And for some people,
simple language can be
very vague and confusing and disorienting,
and can send the message
that you don't think
that they understand things.
So if you don't know,
and if somebody's not responding
clearly, you don't know,
regardless of what someone
else says their I.Q. is,
'cause we don't have great
assessments for distinguishing
between not understanding and
not being able to respond.
But in any case, if you don't know
it's really important
to try simple language,
and it's really important to
also try technical language.
And even if somebody is responding,
if somebody is not
understanding or responding
to your simplified language,
try something else.
Because sometimes the problem
isn't that it's too complicated,
sometimes the problem is
that it's too simplified.
Another thing that's really important,
in recognizing people's humanity
that is less guess-oriented,
is that it's very important
to address people directly,
even if you think the
overwhelming probability is that
somebody no longer understands language,
never did understand language,
has no idea what you're talking about.
It's very important to
directly address them
and not just the people they came with,
and to not just examine someone,
or make a plan for someone.
It's important to address them directly,
and that's beneficial even if it turns out
that they really don't understand you,
because most people have
some understanding of
what's considered respectful
behavior and what's not,
and most people who
don't understand language
do understand being ignored,
and do understand being treated as though
they're irrelevant.
And, a lot of times people do,
and people who do understand
and have a lot of trouble
communicating often give up,
because of despair, because of
just coming to the conclusion
that nobody is ever going
to listen to them anyways,
so why try?
And sending the message that you care,
can help somebody to not give up,
and you might not see the fruits of it,
but it still might be part
of what gets them to a point
where they don't give up and they're able
to communicate later.
So it's part of recognizing humanity,
and it can be beneficial in other ways.
It's often worth saying explicitly
that you're acknowledging the situation.
Like saying things like
'I don't understand what you're saying,'
'I do care what you're saying,'
'your opinion is imporant to me,'
'I want to listen to you.'
Sometimes that doesn't go anywhere,
but sometimes if you
keep doing that over time
people surprise you.
So part of giving people space
to communicate is wait time.
Something that educators
are advised to do,
is when you're lecturing
and you say something,
ask a question, and nobody's responding,
it can feel like an
eternity, and you're like
'oh my God, they must
not have understood me,
I should jump in and clarify,'
it's like this natural instinct
'cause it feels really long,
but what teachers are told,
and they've found that as a
teacher this really matters,
is that you need to wait
at least seven seconds
after you ask a question
before you say anything else,
because it gives people time
to process and formulate responses.
And so, if you're asking questions
and not giving space
for people to respond,
the questions effectively don't get asked.
So with anyone, waiting at least
seven seconds is necessary,
with people with disabilities
it's often necessary to wait longer.
So if somebody is not responding
and is being said to be non-responsive,
sometimes just waiting
longer can be game-changing.
And if somebody uses
alternative communication,
no matter how skilled someone is,
that's going to take longer,
and making it clear that you're willing
to take the time to listen,
and that you're not rushing
through and interrupting
is both respectful and conducive
to actually recognizing
that somebody's perspective
is important, knowing what
it is and acting on it.
So, related to that, people
have a lot of different
communication preferences,
and sometimes if you ask what
they are people can tell you.
Not always, but sometimes asking about
communication preferences
gives somebody space
to feel safe enough to communicate
in a way that isn't typical.
And this is important even
with people where you're like
'oh, he's so high-functioning,
she's so high-functioning,
they're so verbal.'
Just because somebody can talk
in a relatively normal
cadence doesn't mean
that's the best way for
them to communicate,
and most people who can speak
for whom another form of
communication is better
are really afraid of
the reaction they'll get
from educators, from social workers,
from medical professionals.
So asking about
communication preferences and
continuing to ask can be both
effective and respectful.
And even if people
don't take you up on it,
it can still mean that
they're less afraid of you
in other ways.
Related:
asking yes or no questions
can get a lot of mileage
and it works a lot better
if it's planned for.
And a lot of people can actually
answer yes or no questions
but can't initiate explaining
to you how they say yes or no.
So it can be worth asking,
again with appropriate wait time:
can you show me yes, can you show me no?
And thinking in advance: what is it likely
that someone in this
situation, facing this issue,
from this culture, of this age and gender,
might want to be able to tell me,
and writing down some of the
questions they might want.
Because not everyone can use their words,
some people need you to use yours.
If you plan for it, you
can get a lot of mileage
out of yes or no questions,
two choice questions, that are more open,
can get you often more
mileage than yes or no.
For instance, some of
them can be closed like
'do you want x or y?'
but you can also do
things that are more open,
along the lines of 'I
think you're saying x,
am I getting that right, or
did you mean something else?'
And then continuing to
make and check guesses
allows for a surprising
amount of communication,
and I've done this very
effectively with a number of people
who others had told me
are impossible to have
a conversation with.
So even if somebody is saying
things that seem to you to be
complete nonsense, or
non-seqiturs, like random phrases
from television or whatever,
making a guess and asking
them to confirm or deny it,
and acting on the possibility that
it may well be communication,
for some people can open up
a lot of communicative possibilities.
And again, not universal.
For some people this can be heard as
'why are you not ignoring my vocal tick,
what's wrong with you?'
So again, it's about making
and confirming guesses
there are unfortunately very few universal
or well-established things,
but this is often well worth trying.
And, related to documenting
communication and uncertainty,
Related to documenting
doing chaplaincy, I've seen
a lot of people's charts
say that they have no communication,
and in situations where
what that really meant was
they have dementia, or they speak slowly,
or I didn't talk to them.
And writing down that
somebody has no communication
in their chart endangers them,
and it is something that
nobody should ever do.
And that's one of the few
things in this presentation
I'm comfortable saying unequivocally.
It is absolutely never
appropriate to write
in somebody's chart, in
their file, in their I.E.P,
in their educational plan:
this person has no communication,
this person is incapable of conversation.
It can be appropriate to say
'I was not able to find an effective means
of communication with this person,'
because that's what you actually know.
If you didn't communicate with someone,
what you know about that person,
is that you did not successfully
communicate with them.
You don't know what they're thinking,
you don't know what they're
capable of understanding,
capable of communicating
under the right circumstances.
And if you document that somebody
has no capacity for communication,
other people will believe you,
and they will act on that belief,
and it will certainly be
degrading to the person
you say has no communication,
and it can very easily
be life-threatening.
That's again the one thing
that I'm willing to say -
two things I'm willing
to say unequivocally:
everyone has a perspective
that needs to be respected,
and it is absolutely
never appropriate to write
in any sort of documentation or file
that a person has no communication or
no capacity for communication.
And I've done various things
in chaplaincy settings
and other settings with
people who've been told to me
to have no communication,
and one of the people was
a woman who had dementia,
and was past the point of
using sentences very often.
But you know, I was told this
woman has no communication,
and I was also told she
likes to walk around,
she's always trying to walk around,
so we have to strap her
down in her wheelchair
and we give her lorazepam at night
when there's no aid to
walk with her to supervise,
and after about 15 minutes
she stops resisting.
I also saw this person
has no communication,
and I want to be careful on this,
because one thing I'm not
willing to say unequivocally
is behavior is communication.
Because, I mean for a couple of reasons.
One is that I can tell you,
nothing that I have ever done
has been intended to
communicate the message
'please follow me around with a clipboard,
take detailed notes on
everything I do and put me
on a behavior plan,' ever.
And I don't know, if
my life was different,
and I was less lucky and my disabilities
put me in the system, I think
it would be very hard for me
to do anything that was
not seen as communicating
the message 'please follow
me around with a clipboard,
find out what I like, dole
it out in small details
and put me on a behavior plan
that will get me to do what you want.'
So behavior is information,
and movement is not necessarily behavior.
Which is also important,
like if you can't communicate
with somebody in a way
that allows them to confirm
or deny your assumptions,
then you really can't
know what the meaning
of their behavior is,
and even sometimes
whether or not something
is actually behavior.
Because, you know, not all
body motion is intentional,
not all body motion is controlled,
and I think most people get
this about, say like, epilepsy.
If somebody is having
a convulsive seizure,
very few people who are
aware that medicine exists
would call that behavior.
But if somebody has partial
seizures that affect things,
and they're put on a
reinforcement-based behavior plan
based on the presumption that
all communication is behavior,
it's probably solving the wrong problem.
And charting somebody's
behavior and finding
an effective way of modifying it,
is not at all similar to
listening to that person,
and the two are conflated.
And it is very very
important to realize that
'listen to somebody' is not the same as
'find an effective way of
modifying their behavior
to meet perceived needs.'
Because people with disabilities
do not just have needs,
people with disabilities
also have perspectives,
opinions, beliefs,
and those are things that very much
need to be respected in a way
that is really not captured
by what is usually meant by
behavior is communication.
That said, behavior is information.
Behavior is something
that should be looked at,
because it is a source of guesses.
Behavior is information
that is a source of guesses,
and some things that people
do that are not words
are communication.
And part of respecting someone's humanity
is paying attention to
things that are communicated
other than in words.
Which is not the same as
behavior modification,
and I think that, again,
is there a time and place
for behavior modification?
Sometimes. Not as many times
and places as it's used,
but in no case is modifying
behavior the same as listening.
So I'm gonna go back to the
issue of cultural competence
for a minute.
Part of cultural competence
is knowing something about
someone's cultural background,
in an ethnic sense,
in a family sense, in a
crunchy San Francisco sense,
in a they're from conservative
families, whatever.
Part of cultural competence is knowing
what group they come
from in a family sense.
Another part of cultural
competence regarding those cultures
is understanding the range
of meanings disability
in general and communication
disability specifically
might have within that culture.
But another part of cultural
competence is being aware of
the other context someone
might be operating in.
If somebody has a disability,
they may well be connected
to disability cultures of some sort.
And certainly if they're
a person with a disability
who attends special education,
who is institutionalized,
who is in any sort of disability program,
those programs are not just
programs, they're also cultures.
And understanding what
the cultural expectation,
symbolism and responses
in those cultures are
is a pretty key point
in making good guesses
in ways that you can confirm
or deny or respect humanity.
Another aspect of disability
culture is that some people
are connected with self-advocacy
movements of some sort.
Like the intellectual and
developmental disabilities
self-advocacy community has
some very strong cultural norms
that affect what people's
perspectives are like to be
and how they're likely
to interpret what you say
and your behavior.
So part of cultural
competence is being familiar
with that kind of thing,
and being familiar with
what the politically organized
activist communities think
and what other disability
communities think.
Because I think sometimes we
don't want to acknowledge that
these cultural things are
cultures and that they matter,
because we want to say
people with disabilities
are all individuals,
we don't want to make
collective assumptions.
It's true, people are all individuals,
but part of how people's
individuality manifests,
is not only the things
that are unique about them,
but the cultures they're part of
and the things they share
with some other people
that are not universal.
And just like if you're
working with gay patients,
which again, some of the
people you're working with are,
even if you don't know,
understanding the effects that has
not only from a
what-do-people-do-to-you perspective,
but what cultures are you likely part of,
what are the values,
symbols and assumptions
associated with that culture,
is part of cultural competence as much as
finding out what are the
typical ranges of what
people without disabilities in the ethnic,
or religious background,
or racial background
they come from normally have.
So again, every person's
perspective matters
and is important.
Whether or not someone can communicate
in a way you understand,
they're a fully human person.
Whether or not we know
what someone's thinking,
their opinion is important.
Regardless of impairment,
their life is their own.
Even when people don't
understand language,
they probably understand
respectful behavior,
contemptuous behavior,
threatening behavior,
consent-seeking behavior.
So behaving in a way that
takes this into account,
acknowledge that you're making guesses,
that you are going to be
wrong a lot of the time,
because we do not have the
received knowledge of appropriate
communication of people
with disabilities that we do
in a lot of other areas of practice.
And realizing that the fact that
we don't know how to do it
doesn't mean that it's impossible.
We have a saying in Judaism,
his is me be rabbinic, right,
we have a saying in Judaism:
it is not upon you to complete the work,
but neither are you
free to desist from it.
Don't expect to solve the whole problem,
because that's too big for any one person,
but do look at what's in front of you,
what assumptions you can be making,
and what you can figure
out and which problems
you might be able to solve.
So, it's not upon us to complete the work,
let's all go do it, thanks everyone.
(applause)